I'm afraid that you have just been
struck by my nan ability known as sub
water as such this adorable mascot will
now remain with you until you pay off
your debt and look it's about to take
effect you know what to do hello and
welcome to the new world review your
souls for everything anime and manga and
today I'd like to dip back into the
world of hunter hunter as we often do
but specifically to examine the out of
nan and even more specifically not to
discuss named beasts and this is a fun
discussion because nan basic currently a
huge part of the story in the succession
walk
however this concept actually has quite
a rich history in hunter hunter and then
beasts have appeared all over the place
and have been used in some nice unique
ways furthermore they're also not quite
as easy to identify and classify as you
may initially think so before we move on
let's discuss the commonly accepted
definition of an n beast essentially an
N beast is an existence that refers to a
seemingly living being brought into
existence usually through conjuration
but it can also be achieved through
other means and generally controlled via
manipulation from here these beasts can
also have abilities of their own most of
the time also being under the control of
the user but there have certainly been
instances of Nan beasts who operate as
their own independent existence and even
have their own sub classification of an
affinity but for our initial example
let's look at the simple figure of
Gerena
who has the ability to bring two
gorillas like creatures into existence
which are named white Cortina and black
Carini respectively now exactly what
method of nan Korena uses to bring these
creatures into existence is currently
unknown and I guess it could be basic
conjuration but there is a great
argument to be made for a mission as
well due to their exact abilities now
Gerena himself is a natural manipulator
which is the method by which he is able
to command these simian friends and he
does so telepathically by the way but
the grander purpose these gorillas serve
is allowing Goryeo to mess around with
general placement so for example why
chorinho allows regular Garino to switch
places at any time that's essentially
teleporting the two of them while black
arena does the same but instead it
allows greener to pick another target if
he's choosing to teleport into the
position of the second day so through
very incredible use it would allow
garena to have complete control over
maneuverability on a battlefield or very
simply to allow quarry neo to always
have a dedicated escape route and that
isn't to say that this is the only way
that the Greeners can be used as well
because they are also capable of
physically interacting with the world
around them so you could theoretically
use them for combative purposes or even
just to carry out general day-to-day
tasks very importantly though this
particular case of Nan beasts requires
Garino to always be conscious
like controlling the gorillas and if he
loses focus in these beasts will
dissipate and to look for a similar
example we can find that in Raisa who
used his own in beast to compete
directly against Karina in the greed
Island dodgeball match which in his case
allows him to create a series of
anthropomorphic beasts labeled with the
number 0 through 7 and given that this
is known as the 14 Devils han-soo these
beasts can also combine together to form
larger numbers and thus become far far
more powerful but just as with Gerena we
aren't entirely sure how these beasts
come into existence but in razors case
it's much more likely to be a result of
a mission simply because he is a natural
emitter and to such conjuration would be
raises weakest discipline of nen whereas
garena was a manipulator and so
conjuration is one step easier to access
at a potent level but in this case razor
created his nen beast with a physical
purpose in mind I mean in this case to
play dodgeball I guess but they would
also serve as easy access to a nice
miniature army in a battle type
situation although it should be stated
that with these beasts activated razor
is incapable of using any way near his
full or output and the beasts themselves
each have a small share of aura that
becomes greater and greater as they fuse
together but it leaves Razer himself
unable to operate and his maximum
individual capacity but not everyone
uses an NBC for such a straightforward
purpose and in some rare cases the nen
base can act as more of a curse and they
do a benefit and to see an example of
this we now stick to Creed Island and
turn to up and gunner who practices a
very niche form of men known as nan
exorcism and this basically allows up
and gonna to remove nan curses placed
upon others and an example of an end
curse would be crop occurs judgment
shame whereby he can enforce a rule on a
person and if they break that rule and
they are immediately killed simply yeah
but Albin Ghana is a unique existence
who is able to remove those curses
however he also happens to be a natural
conjurer which means the way in which he
frees people from these afflictions is
to conjure an in beast who devours the
curses that that beast will then linger
upon up and Gani until the original
criteria for dispelling the curse is met
and the beast in question becomes larger
in direct correlation to the power of
the curse that consumed leaving Alban
Gani with the curse of his own
essentially in the form of an n beast so
when I beg on his case the Beast is
certainly not a desirable outcome but it
does show how they can be used for an
incredible array of different purposes
but NIMBYs can exist as a construct not
to really be used at all and to take on
an almost completely independent role in
the world of men and Here I am talking
specifically about the guardian spirit
beasts who are currently being used in
the succession war now these guys do
differ quite radically from what we've
explored thus far
because while beasts are assigned to
each quote-unquote user they were not
actually brought into existence by the
princes of the car cane Empire
themselves not even the rare ones who
did know about men prior to the contest
commencing in fact these beasts were
actually conscious via a process
involving what I'm assuming is
post-mortem men left behind by the
previous [ __ ] in monarchs all of which
seems to be concentrated in an object
known as the seed on which was directly
conjured at the very first [ __ ] in king
and so after completing a simple
ceremony in which Prince commits an
offering of blood into the urn they are
then fed in an egg which eventually
develops into a full-on man-beast which
as with most established forms of men
takes inspiration from the desires and
feelings of their specific user however
due to the fact that they weren't
specifically conjured by those whom they
are bound to during the succession
contests the printers cannot actually
control their beasts or at the very
least they can't yet furthermore the
princes can't even see any of the beasts
that have been conjured as part of the
war even once they have learnt about nan
well the beasts aren't visible to any
other nen user indicating that this
vision issue is probably one of the many
many restrictions put in place to make
this incredible power possible because
the beasts that have come into existence
here are unlike anything we've seen
before these aren't the basic mindless
drones that we saw with Gauri no eraser
and in fact many of the beasts come
equipped with nen abilities of their own
and are even granted a natural affinity
in one of the six nine categories thus
effectively making these nan beasts nan
uses themselves which is a a bit of a
weird thing to think about in addition
to this though at least two princes
involved in the succession war have
their own personal nan beasts
one of which is 4th Prince erotic it was
such a naturally gifted user that he
just up and summoned a second and Beast
entirely subconsciously now Sarai dick
is a specialist so it's not immediately
apparent as to the ground that he may
have taken to create this beast
although conjuration would be a natural
thought because it's right next to
specialization on the nin ring and we're
also not entirely sure what it does
right now but it may be connected to
surroundings parallel future Honsou even
though he needs to be in a state of
zetsu to use it which in theory would
dispel the Beast for that so that's a
whole different story I think I've gone
into it before so we won't do it here
but we should also touch on Camilla who
has access to a terrifying nan beast in
the form of a giant kitty cat and one of
the more interesting conditions for use
that we've seen in the series being that
Camilla has to be killed for this hot
suit to activate after which the cats
born into existence
possibly through the wonders again of
post-mortem nan and drains the life of
whoever killed Camilla and reinserted
into her thus reviving Camilla from
death and killing her would-be murderer
but we do need to get a bit
from here because as I mentioned in the
beginning of this video ninh base do
reach a point where they become very
difficult to define now all of the
examples I've listed a pretty schmick
and easy because they all involve a
source of conjuration or emission to
craft a beast but if we expand the
definition to transmutation then we have
some gray area scenarios one such
example would be Morrel who was able to
transmute his aura directly into smoke
via the use of his oversized pipe and
then use a further combination of a
mission and manipulation to craft and
control the smokey constructs of which
he is even capable of giving a
naturalistic appearance so emission is
still involved but the main vehicle here
is actually transmutation and I'm not
entirely sure where we draw the line
here in regards to considering Morel
smoky creations as nen beasts another
tricky designation would be the example
of Zeno zoldak who has the ability to
transmute his aura into the shape of a
dragon which he continues to maintain
control of without the need for
manipulation to come into it and this is
clearly pure aura we're talking about
and it does involve some sort of
emission as well because Zeno can send
it far far away from his body but what
we called the dragon head hot so in an
beasts look I'm not so sure and there
are other examples as well like knuckles
Hawk awara hatsue because I can only
assume that a PR and IRS would be
considered a technical form of Nan beast
both of which were brought into
existence through a mission and
manipulation so they do fit the bill
they just both serve a very unique
purpose one of which is to measure debt
and the other is there to enforce the
state of zetsu and when you think about
it there really are a ton of other
characters who make technical use of an
n beast like Biscay who can transmute
and manipulate cookie into existence and
give wonderful massages so she has a
human form but cookie is surely an N
beast here and if that's our accepted
definition then it is hard to deny moral
smoke troops and Zino's dragon into
having that classification as well but
Nimbus had been a core aspect of hunter
hunter and there is a ton that I haven't
even touched on in this video but
they're a cool feature that are even
integrated into abilities that we
wouldn't immediately think they'd be
part of it's easy to consider them as
summoned beings to do your bidding
whether that be combat dodgeball or
massages but they can be implemented
into a variety of complex ways each with
their own strange benefits and
restrictions and just like the ball of
men in general the sub classification of
men base holds an infinite amount of
potential and I very much look forward
to seeing more of them when the series
progresses but that pretty much does it
for this discussion on end beasts if you
enjoyed this video and the content this
channel produced in general then please
do consider donating to the new world
free patreon because the support of all
of you
using people is what continues to make
this channel possible and if patreon
isn't quite your style then please do
leave this video like share or subscribe
because it also helps support this
channel an incredible amount and if
you'd like to join the fun at any time
and please do head over to mine discord
server where a wide array of nanny Marie
takes place on a daily basis and finally
please do comment with your thoughts on
nen beasts this has been the new world
review and I'll see you next time
his nephew Peter the strongest among the
three Royal Guards that depends I guess
some what you mean by strongest if you
were just talking about you know a
traditional royal power then I'd say
that you pee at the very least
outclasses Peter but the reason why I
would always consider Peto to be above
you pee is simply because Peter is a
specialist being a specialist with that
insane or capacity gives Peter almost
limitless potential like they were able
to come up with at least three
incredibly ridiculous abilities and if
Peter needed more for other specific
purposes then I have no doubt that their
natural talent would have catered for
that whereas you pee and Shia proof they
were also insane don't get me wrong but
their natural affinities of enhancement
and manipulation respectively
do heavily restrict their ultimate
abilities which isn't a problem at all
facing off against human opponents but
if you were to compare the Royal Guard
simply against each other
veto just has such a massive advantage
by being a member of the specialist
class